he was really good as last time out
eight innings one run ball five hits no
walks 11 strikeouts he's got that 279
earned run average 178 strikeouts both
of those ranked second in the american
league reyes said first pitch is cut out
at hit to right field but t oscar is
there anderson's retired on one pitch
went away janman kata the right-handed
hitter getting ready to face ray the
one-two pitch out of the line swing and
a miss got him with a slider
monkatta goes in the glove
abby ray working with two answer under
at first base and brea will be moving on
the pitch there he goes
come on and missed robbie ray with a
couple of strikeouts the white sox will
leave a base runner on lucas giolito
he's been really really good the last
three stars since the all-star break
he's been a different pitcher he's
really putting himself in position just
like he did last year to be one of the
best pitchers on this staff from the
stretch with the runner at third a 2-2
swing gonna miss that's the change-up
and hernandez is down on strikes and the
blue jays will lead the man in scoring
position
top of the second inning here at rogers
center luis robert andrew vaughn and
cesar hernandez
corey dickerson right on the warning
track as he holds it in luis robert
flies out to deep left field that was a
high slider
you can wash away those bad plays as
square dickerson gets another shot at
that fly ball to left field ray working
quickly and the one two swinging to miss
got him with a slider
third strikeout for robbie ray and the
white sox done quickly here in the top
of the second inning blue jays coming to
the plate scoreless corey dickerson
leads it off 3-2 pitch
swinging a miss tipped it off into the
glove nickerson's down on strikes and
that's the second strikeout for lucas
giolito
here in the third semi-zavela the 2-2
swing and a miss another strikeout for
robbie ray that's his fourth on the
night tim anderson he lined the first
pitch he saw to right field there's
another great slider from robbie ray
anderson strikes out back-to-back
strikeouts after the lead-off single
here in the third garcia takes third two
stolen bases here in this third inning
go on the other way and that drops in
and will score a run thanks to the base
running of garcia moncada has an rbi
single he's got a 12-game hit streak and
the lead for the sox
got him come right back with that slider
bridget the right-handed batter steering
out geolito pivots forward 2-2
robert
has out number one santiago espinal
riding a six-game hit streak comes to
the plate
2-2
another change three in a row for strike
three
pitch to bow that's in the air out to
deep left field vaughn going back shy of
the track squares up and he pulls it up
are in the fourth
annoyment goes after the first pitch
nice hop for espinal at third base
menace is retired one down louise robert
bats after one pitch out from eloy
jimenez
the one-two pitch swinging a miss
there's another strikeout
strikeout number seven for robbie ray
andrew vaughn the batter lefty throws
swinging to miss he got him with a
slider why not go back to the bread and
butter back-to-back strikeouts for
robbie ray and eight
are down swinging tonight tying run at
first with one out to oscar hernandez
steps in
struck him out changeup just dived out
of the zone that's nasty i mean nasty
two away in the fourth inning corey
dickerson's over one the pitch there's a
swing and a line drive to the gap at
right center field garcia's on the move
he can't get there this will go all the
way to the wall guerrero is flying
around the bases in stridey taps third
he's coming to the plate standing up and
it's an rbi triple we are tied
on an rbi triple for corey dickerson
garcia has scored the only white sox run
another great slider hump up nine
strikeouts for robbie ray we're tied 1-1
here in toronto sebi zavala
the o2 swinging a miss zavala is down on
strikes and for the seventh time this
season robbie ray
has struck out ten or more tied one one
lord ascorial junior 3-2
swinging a line drive sinking into left
field on comes bond leans out and he
makes the diving catch sinking line
drive into left field vaughn decided to
leave his feet while falling forward
that'll bring up randall grichik
2-2 change just fell completely off the
table
two down
one one game probably ray
jams tim anderson with the first pitch
espinal throws him out one down here in
the top of the six from the bat of
janman cotto his third time in against
robbie ray back together the one two
swinging a miss another strikeout for
robbie ray three out of the last four
have been fanned by robbie ray and owns
his 11th strikeout runners on it first
and second here in the sixth luis robert
the batter
swing and a miss how about a dozen
robbie ray with 12 strikeouts and he
retires the white sox here on the six
runners on it first and second for
alejandro kirk two one two out
to short tim is there he bobbles it
throws to first and kirk is out he
wasn't running out of the box and the
sox get the benefit of kirk not gunning
it down the line robbie ray returns to
the rogers center mound tied 1-1 with
chicago going into the seventh inning
it's in the air fly ball into shallow
left
bow bouchette out he's there the
shortstop makes the catch funds retired
one down zavala will back for himself
here with first in second in one out
got it
what a big pitch by robbie ray as zavala
strikes out for a third time that's 13
strikeouts for robbie ray
now to the top of the order and tim
anderson the o2 to anderson swinging a
miss robbie ray clinches his fists he
gets anderson on strikes robbie ray gets
the best of ta he keeps it a 1-1 game
with seven scintillating innings tonight
at rogers center from the lefty robbie
ray as kirk tries to break through for
toronto here in the eighth go ahead run
up back at second oscar takes off in
kirk finds a base hit up the middle into
center field hernandez will score and
the blue jays have the lead rbi base hit
from alejandro kirk 2-1 toronto here in
the eighth gridzick bats with the bases
loaded
ball for a rental come in ruiz walks
grichik with the bases loaded valeria
comes in to score and it's 3-1 blue jays
blue jays three white sox won cesar
hernandez steps in two and two
popped up this should do it
kritchik's in center and he makes the
catch and that's the ball game